This is my "BeVagilant" campaign
And I want everyone to grow a pair.
I'm a pussy for peace
not a piece of pussy.
The guy sexually assaulted women,
he invaded their space
and he bragged about it.
And that makes me so angry.
We've established over the last eight years
are really positive image of our country in general
and Donald Trump
not only has not enough foreign policy experience but
his diplomacy skills are minimal at best.
Protests are great because
they make our voice really loud
but they don't actually necessarily
accomplish anything policy-wise.
But what it does, is that it shows
me, and us, and everybody here that
tons of people care about the things that we care about.
That we are not alone.
And I think it does make us feel like a more
United States of America.
As a pro-life feminist,
a pro-life libertarian,
they have formally kicked out
a new wave feminists, pro-life feminists
out of this organization.
But as feminists
and libertarians we do not need
permission and we do not need an invitation.
If feminists
see that there are free market feminists,
pro-life feminists, then they'll be willing
to engage in civil conversation with us
we can talk about these issues.
I was disturbed
with the whole protest
that Woman's March was against sex workers
and their rights under the law.
So it seemed important to me even though I'm a
pastor's wife. I'm not in favor of
prostitution.
As a libertarian
if that's your choice
I think that all women, and men for that matter,
should have equal protection under the law.
Trump really
validates and perpetuates Islamophobia.
And it's shocking that in this day and age
we can vilify people by
the beliefs that they hold, the religion that they have,
and the country that they are from,
and how their names sound.
It is illegal to braid hair
in this country.
In America black hair is
under attack and I was arrested in '97.
My livelihood was taken 20 years away from me.
And I just won my case last year.
People create their own occupation
want to go to work for whatever it is that they
naturally do.
If you have a license that is
government regulated than that
stopped the livelihood of someone like
little bitty me in a disenfranchised
community who just wants to uplift my
community and feed my own five children
so that's what occupational license does.